Du als Weißer kannst gerne mit Neonazis
sprechen, mit AfD-Wähler:innen sprechen.
Ich möchte mich nicht mit Leuten
auseinandersetzen, die mich tot sehen
-wollen.
-Also ich glaube nicht, dass die dich tot
-sehen wollen.
-Lass mich bitte aussprechen.
Wir starten direkt mit der ersten
Frage von 13 Fragen, mit unserer Konfliktfrage:
Führt Identitätspolitik zu einer gerechteren
Gesellschaft? Wenn ihr sagt
Ja, führt sie, dann geht ihr aufs
grüne Feld. Und wenn ihr sagt Nein, sie spaltet
unsere Gesellschaft, dann geht ihr aufs
gelbe Feld. Identitätspolitik, das ist
auf den ersten Blick ein großer,
komplizierter Begriff. Dabei ist
es eigentlich ganz einfach: Es geht
um Gruppen in unserer Gesellschaft,
die auf verschiedene Art und Weise
benachteiligt sind. Diese betonen laut
ihre Identität, also Merkmale wie Geschlecht,
Herkunft oder Hautfarbe.
Der Grund ist, sie wollen gehört,
anerkannt und gleichberechtigt werden.
Die Frage ist: Ist das der richtige
Weg, um Gleichberechtigung für alle
zu erreichen? Oder spaltet
Identitätspolitik unsere Gesellschaft
sogar noch mehr? Schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare,
was ihr dazu denkt. Es ist
nicht selten passiert, dass Menschen
ihre Meinung nach unseren Folgen geändert
haben. Dann heißt es für euch ab
jetzt: Wenn ihr einem Argument der Gegenseite
zustimmen wollt, dann geht ihr einen
Schritt auf die andere weiter zu.
Und wenn ihr vielleicht sogar
sauer seid, während jemand anderes sagt
und das zum Ausdruck bringen wollt,
dann geht ihr einen Schritt nach hinten.
Ich möchte mit dir starten, Emilia.
Lass uns doch mal über diesen komplexen Begriff
"Identitätspolitik" sprechen. Was für einen
Sinn steckt eigentlich dahinter?
Identitätspolitik ist eigentlich
nichts anderes als Bewegungen für die Befreiung
von unterdrückten Menschen.
Und deswegen gibt es das Gefühl,
dass es die Gesellschaft spaltet,
weil es triggert. Es triggert die Menschen,
die bisher über die Macht verfügt
haben. Und es gibt einen Spruch, der sagt,
dass Menschen, die bisher
privilegiert waren, Gleichberechtigung
wie Diskriminierung empfinden. Das Thema
liegt mir am Herzen, weil ich mich
für eine gerechte Welt engagieren
will, weil ich nicht mehr schweigen möchte.
Ich mache das für mich,
für die Generationen vor mir
und für die Generationen nach mir. Es ist
möglich, in einer unterdrückungsfreien
Welt anzukommen, einfach nur,
wenn wir kollektiv mutig sind dafür.
Kann Identitätspolitik
nur von Minderheiten kommen?
Ja, weil es ist auf keinen Fall
möglich, z.B. die White Power oder die Neo-Nazi
Bewegung mit identitätspolitischen
Bewegungen von Minderheiten
-zu vergleichen.
-Da spalten sich auch die Meinungen, oder?
Also es gibt auch Expert:innen,
die sagen...
Ja, aber ich würde sagen z.B.
Neonazis. Also ihr Ziel ist eben, die Überlegenheit
der weißen Rasse zu proklamieren
und Minderheiten zu unterdrücken bis hin
zu vernichten und z.B. Black Lives
Matter Bewegung oder die MeToo-Bewegung: Das Ziel
ist nicht, andere zu unterdrücken,
ganz und gar nicht, sondern es geht darum,
Gleichberechtigung, Gleichheit,
Sichtbarkeit und Respekt zu gewinnen.
-Also es geht quasi...
-Ich würde nicht bei Minderheiten bleiben,
weil es geht für mich eher um Macht
und die historische Komponente.
Aber es geht um politische Mehrheiten
und politische Minderheiten. Zum Beispiel sind
Frauen statistisch gesehen auch in der Mehrheit
und dennoch weil sie über weniger
Macht, über weniger Zugang zu Ressourcen,
über weniger Deutungshoheit verfügen,
-sind sie in der Minderheit.
-Also je nach dem wie man den Begriff
-"Minderheit" genau versteht.
-Wieso brauchen wir denn deiner Meinung
nach, Emilia, Identitätspolitik
für den Kampf um Gleichberechtigung?
Weil es um Befreiung geht. Wie ist es denn
möglich, über Rassismus zu sprechen,
ohne über die betroffenen Menschen
zu sprechen? Wie ist es denn möglich,
über Behindertenfeindlichkeit zu sprechen,
ohne die Stimmen von behinderten Menschen
in den Vordergrund zu stellen? Das gleiche
gilt für Frauen, für die LGBTIQ-Gruppen.
Deswegen ist es unerlässlich. Und es ist
nicht die Identitätspolitik, die spaltet,
-sondern es ist der Widerstand dagegen.
-Ich wollte euch gerade fragen, ob ihr
einen Schritt auf Emilia
zugeht, aber ihr seid alle einen Schritt
auf sie zugegangen. Simon,
warum bist du auf sie zugegangen?
Man kann die Unterdrückung
gewisser Personen natürlich nicht behandeln,
ohne es anzusprechen, welche
Gruppen unterdrückt werden. Ich finde,
Identitätspolitik kann bis zu einem
gewissen Grad schon hilfreich sein,
um auf gewisse Themen aufmerksam zu machen.
Aber wenn es zu extrem betrieben
wird, dann heißt es z.B., weil man
ein "weißer heterosexueller Cis-Mann" ist,
dass man zu manchen Themen gar nicht
mehr die Meinung sagen darf. Und das trägt dazu
bei, dass die Meinung ein bisschen
eingeschränkt wird. Aber was mich
interessieren würde: Du hast ganz
am Anfang sowas gesagt wie "die weiße
Bevölkerung" oder sowas, die die Macht
hat, die sind getriggert, wenn man
ausspricht, dass sie die Macht haben
und die sind da dagegen. Würdest du somit
sagen, weil ich weiß bin, hab ich Macht
über dich? Oder wen meinst du mit "die
-Weißen, die die Macht haben"?
-Wir leben in einer Gesellschaft, die so
strukturiert ist, dass weiß sein ganz
oben in der Hierarchie gestellt ist.
Deshalb hast du keine Macht über
mich so direkt individuell gesehen,
aber gesellschaftlich gesehen.
Weiße Menschen verfügen über diese Macht.
Sie verfügen über die Macht in den Medien,
in der Politik, im Bildungssystem,
in allen Bereichen des
gesellschaftlichen Lebens.
Aber in Deutschland ist es ja logisch,
dass mehr weiße Menschen die Macht haben,
-da es mehr Weiße gibt.
-Aber es ist überall so. Es ist global so.
Aber ist es richtig,
nur weil es logisch ist?
Also du willst jetzt quasi z.B.,
dass in der Regierung gleichviel Weiße
und Schwarze sind, obwohl es viel
weniger Schwarze gibt?
Aber geht es bei der Macht
darum, wie viele es gibt?
Ne ne ne, Logisch, dass Weiße mehr
Macht haben als andere Personengruppen.
Und ich glaube, es geht ja
nicht darum, wie viele Menschen wo sind,
sondern wie viel mehr kannst du
machen. Wenn du zum Beispiel einen Namen hättest,
der Teil einer privilegierten Gruppe
wäre, dann hast du die Macht, dass du mehr
Wohnungen bekommen kannst als die andere
Person. Und das ist etwas, womit man
auch kokettieren kann und was man
auch benutzen kann. Das ist nicht so "Ich
verprügelt dich jetzt", sondern das sind
subtilere Dinge, wie du Macht ausübst.
Ich glaube, dass sogenannte
Identitätspolitik uns dabei helfen kann,
die Bedürfnisse der einzelnen
Menschen irgendwie besser anzugehen. Und wenn du
genau weißt, was diese Person gerade
durchlebt oder was vielleicht kollektive
Erfahrungen sind, die das Leben
schwieriger machen, dann kann man
es auch leichter
verbessern, das Leben dieser Person.
-Aber ich übe da doch nicht die Macht aus.
-Du übst vielleicht aktiv keine Macht aus,
aber der Fakt ist, dass du
privilegiert bist vom System.
-Ja, aber...
-Unter einigen Aspekten, aber nicht unter
allen Aspekten. Also ich meine jeder
von uns ist einerseits privilegiert
und anderseits nicht privilegiert.
Ich habe einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht,
weil du, Malcolm, gesagt hast, es geht
um Macht. Das ist der Punkt. Aber das hat
mit Identität nichts zu tun. Oder zumindest
ist nicht die Identitätspolitik
die Lösung. Wenn ich z.B. über
meine eigene Identität spreche, ist
das ein Prisma wie die Identität von jedem
Mensch. Ich habe verschiedene Facetten:
Ich bin eine Frau, ein Sizilianerin,
eine Italienerin, aber keine
von diesen Etiketten bestimmt meinen
Wert und beschreibt mich als ganze Person.
Wenn ich einer Gruppe angehöre, heißt
das überhaupt nicht, dass ich dieselben Werte
teile wie die anderen Leute, die in der selben
Gruppe sind. Eine Frau
zu sein heißt nicht Feministin zu sein z.B.
Ich bin Feministin, aber es gibt ganz
viele Frauen, die für eine patriarchale
Struktur der Gesellschaft sind
und ich teile meine feministische
Perspektive mit vielen Männern
-zum Beispiel.
-Warum führt sie denn deiner Meinung nach
-zu mehr Ausgrenzung?
-Weil sie die Leute in Schubladen, in
Kategorien steckt, die immer zu eng
sind, weil jeder von uns hat verschiedene
Identitäten. Wir haben nicht nur eine Identität.
Und das heißt, ich möchte
mit den Leuten kämpfen, die meine gleichen
politischen Werte teilen und nicht
auch von Italienern vertreten werden
z.B,. weil es gibt ganz viele Italiener,
die politische Werte
vertreten, die ganz andere sind als meine.
Also dieses laut Identität betonen, sich
- ich sage jetzt mal, ich zitiere dich jetzt
mal "in Kategorien
einordnen", das findest du nicht gut?
-Überhaupt nicht gut.
-Mich würde auch interessieren, was ihr
darüber denkt: Müssen wir Gruppenidentitäten
überhaupt erst einmal
sichtbar machen? Also Frauen,
Menschen mit Behinderungen, BPOCs,
homosexuelle Menschen, um überhaupt
erst einmal klarzustellen, dass diese überhaupt
-diskriminiert werden darf?
-Darf ich gleich was dazu sagen? Es geht ja
auch gar nicht darum, dich oder jemand
anderen zu beschränken in der Identität.
Natürlich ist deine Identität nicht
damit geklärt, dass du sagst Ich bin eine Frau.
Natürlich haben wir alle viel
mehr Facetten oder so, aber auch du
als Feministin, wenn du
einen feministischen Kampf führst
oder für feministische Werte
politisch etwas vertrittst oder so, dann
ob die es wollen oder nicht oder ob die es wissen
oder nicht, dann kämpfst du
auch für die Frauen, die sich
nicht als Feministinnen betrachten.
Genau, weil ich kämpfe für universelle
Rechte und nicht für besondere Rechte,
-für besondere Kategorien.
-Geht ja nicht um besondere Rechte, es geht
um Gleichberechtigung. Mir
persönlich liegt das Thema sehr am Herzen, denn
wir leben in einer Gesellschaft, die sexistisch,
die rassistisch sozialisiert
ist und es besteht ein Ungleichgewicht,
ein Machtgefälle. Es ist Fakt,
dass gewisse Gruppen von Menschen
unterdrückt werden und das System andere
Leute klar bevorteilt. Und wenn wir Gerechtigkeit
wollen, dann müssen
-wir das ändern.
-Ich glaube, das ist eine sehr reduzierende
Art und Weise, Identitätspolitik zu sehen,
weil das heißt im Grunde so ganz pauschal:
Wir sehen Okay, alle Frauen müssen
so denken, alle Männer müssen so denken.
Es geht überhaupt nicht
darum. Identitätspolitik sind
Befreiungsbewegungen, die gegen Systeme,
die gegen Unterdrückungssystem vorgehen.
Das heißt, Feminismus
ist Identitätspolitik und geht
-gegen das Patriarchat vor.
-Warum bezeichnest du Feminismus als eine
-Identitätspolitik?
-Weil wir heute über Identitätspolitik
diskutieren und das ist im Grunde eine Befreiungsbewegung,
wie ich gerade gesagt
-habe.
-Ist die Arbeiterbewegung für dich eine
Identitätsbewegung? Die Bewegung
für die Rechte der Arbeitnehmer?
Es sind alles Identitäten, die auf uns
projiziert werden. Klasse ist
auch eine Identität, die auf uns
projiziert wird. Klasse ist, wie wir uns
anziehen, was wir essen, wie wir sprechen.
Das heißt, wir tragen das auch in uns.
Und deshalb: Ein Stück weit können wir auch trotzdem
von einer Identitätspolitik
sprechen. Aber ich spreche
lieber von Befreiungsbewegungen.
Ich will aber schon eingestehen: Es gibt
einen Strang oder es gibt schon Menschen,
die Identitätspolitik sehr undifferenziert
ausüben und die wirklich nur sagen "Du
musst allen Schwarzen glauben!"
und "Du musst allen Frauen glauben!"
oder oder oder. Und ich sehe
solche Phrasen auf Instagram, ich sehe das,
dass Leute sowas sagen. Ich sehe
Leute, die sagen "Du bist weiß und blablabla".
Also ich weiß was du meinst, wenn du
sagst, es ist nicht Identitätspolitik,
aber manche Leute verhalten sich
so, dass der Eindruck entsteht, das sei
Identitätspolitik. Und ich kann
verstehen, dass man da einen Widerstand hat. Und man
muss auch anerkennen, es ist nicht
alles so glasklar. Es gibt immer verschiedene
Nuancen. Ich kann jetzt nicht
deine Erfahrungen genau gleichsetzen
mit einer anderen Person, nur weil die beiden
Wurzeln in Europa haben.
Und manchmal passiert es aber und dann
gibt es Safe Spaces, da können dann keine
Weißen rein, aber weil ich Albaner
bin habe ich vielleicht trotzdem
Diskriminierung erfahren. Und das ist
etwas, was ich nachvollziehen kann.
Aber ich würde nicht diese Menschen
exemplarisch nehmen für diese ganze
-Bewegung.
-Simon, du bist gerade einen Schritt auf
-Malcolm zugegangen, warum?
-Du hast ja vorher am Anfang bei deinem
Statement gesagt, die Leute sind kein
Fan der Identitätspolitik, weil die Weißen
fühlen sich getriggert durch das Ganze.
Ich glaube das, was er beschrieben hat,
das ist eher der Grund,
warum Leute sich getriggert fühlen
von der Identitätspolitik, weil es dann
auf einmal heißt Ja, du bist weiß und du
darfst da überhaupt nicht mitreden bei den ganzen
Themen, weil du bist ja zu wenig
unterdrückt oder sowas. Das glaube
ich ist, warum das die meisten Leute...
Ich glaube oft übersetzt man es so.
Vielleicht wird gesagt: Hey, du bist weiß,
hast du überhaupt eine Erfahrung mit Rassismus?
Ist es jetzt wichtig, dass du
deinen Senf dazu abgibst? Und es kann
aber sein, dass manche Leute das übersetzen
als "Du verbietest es mir jetzt,
weil ich nicht unterdrückt genug bin." Also
ich muss auch sagen, manchmal
werden Dinge auch bewusst missverstanden.
Das stimmt. Also wenn du jetzt über
deine Rassismuserfahrungen redest, dann kann
ich natürlich nicht sagen "ne, die Rassismuserfahrungen
hast du nicht so,
weil ich keine Rassismuserfahrungen
habe. Das würde ja überhaupt gar keinen Sinn
-ergeben.
-BRKN, ich würde gerne nochmal auf dich zu
sprechen kommen, du hast dich gerade
das erste Mal bewegt als einer der letzten
sage ich mal, ohne es zu bewerten.
Warum würdest du denn sagen,
dass Identitätspolitik
aus deiner Sicht wichtig ist?
Identitätspolitik klingt ein bisschen
so nach Egoismus. Identitätspolitik klingt so
ein bisschen nach "Ich bin das und ihr müsst
alle auf mich hören!" oder so.
Und darum geht es ja gar nicht. Es geht
ja auch gar nicht um jede einzelne
individuelle Forderung, die irgendein
Mensch haben sollte, sondern es geht
da einfach um bewiesene Strukturen
und Benachteiligungen, wo man sagt Ey,
-das sollte einfach nicht so sein.
-Und würdest du sagen, dass
Identitätspolitik das erreicht,
dass irgendwann alle alle Rechte haben?
Ich denke es ist notwendig, weil irgendwie
muss man ja seine Stimme hörbar machen.
Und am Ende des Tages
ist es wahrscheinlich Politik,
-wenn ich meine Stimme hörbar machen will
-Aber welche Stimme? Nicht alle Leute, die
in eine Gruppe sind, haben
dieselbe Stimme, das ist der Punkt.
Nein, aber es geht doch nicht
um individuelle Erfahrungen. Es geht
um vorhandene, bewiesene
strukturelle Benachteiligungen.
Mirza, ich würde gern
hören, was du dazu sagen möchtest.
Ich könnte genauso auf dieser Seite
stehen, also im Herzen bin ich genauso
grün. Für mich persönlich ist
das Thema Identitätspolitik wichtig,
weil ich in diesem Land geboren
und aufgewachsen bin und natürlich
auch als Kind von Migranten auch selbst
betroffen bin. Und es ist das Ergebnis
von einer ganz besonderen
Generation, die es geschafft hat, dass wir heute
Identitätspolitik betreiben dürfen,
die aber auch mit Vorsicht zu genießen ist.
Ich kann die Position von Simon
auch sehr gut verstehen, wenn er sagt,
dass es anfängt, dass mein Wort
keine Gewichtung hat oder ich ausgeschlossen
werde, weil ich weiß bin oder aus München
oder aus Deutschland, wie auch immer.
Dann fangen wir damit an eigentlich
genau mit den selben Mitteln zu arbeiten,
wie die Leute, die wir eigentlich
versuchen zu bekämpfen
in Anführungsstrichen. Simon und ich und alle
diese beteiligten Personen sind
Deutschland. Und Simon
darf nicht ausgeschlossen werden,
nur weil er das ist, was er ist.
Das ist meine Ausgangssituation.
Emilia, du hast dich
einen Schritt auf Mirza zubewegt.
Ja, genau, weil das ist richtig zu sagen:
Wir dürfen nicht die gleichen Mittel
verwenden, die gegen uns verwendet
werden. Also im Grunde, wie Lorde sagt: "You can
not dismantle the masters house with
the masters tools". Darum geht es. Aber
ich glaube, das ist eine Interpretationsfrage.
Das heißt,
viele Menschen interpretieren
die Tatsache, dass minorisierte Gruppen
für sich sprechen und sich
behaupten und sich empowern, als Bedrohung.
Und deswegen haben sie eine Art
von defensiver Haltung dagegen,
weil sie unterschwellig und unbewusst
das Gefühl haben "Oh, da kommt Rache."
Was würdest du denn sagen, ist deiner
Meinung nach der Nachteil oder das Problem
-an der Identitätspolitik?
-Wenn wir - also und das ist das so ein
bisschen, was ich aus der Social Media
Blase so ein bisschen beobachten kann ist,
dass Menschen anfangen, sich
bestimmte Themen zu einer Berufung zu machen
und dann nur noch durch diese Brille
auf die Themen schauen. Das ist das,
was ich beobachte. Ich sehe sehr viele
Aktivisten oder Aktivistinnen, die nicht
mehr der Sache dienen, sondern auch ganz
viel sich selbst dienen und sich damit
etablieren in verschiedenen
Themen. Man sieht immer dieselben Figuren
in verschiedenen Debatten im Fernsehen
oder in verschiedenen Formaten. Und dann
wiederum frage ich mich: Dies führt
doch dazu, dass diese Leute, die ihre Karrieren
damit machen und auch die so wie ich,
die dann Abnehmer sind auf der anderen Seite,
aus dieser Nummer nicht mehr
rauskommen. Also wann können wir dann eine gemeinsame
Identität entwickeln? Das ist
für mich diese Frage, die sich stellt.
-Darf ich dazu noch was sagen?
-Ja, klar. Also das Problem, was du benannt
hast, das kann ich verstehen.
Gerade in linken Kreisen gibt es irgendwie
diesen Wettkampf "wer ist woker"?
Und wenn dann jemand einmal was falsches
gesagt hat innerhalb des linken
Spektrums, dann ist voll die Aufruhr und so,
anstatt zu sagen, ey es gibt ein bisschen
größere Probleme als wer ist am linkesten
oder wer ist am voguesten. Aber die strukturelle
Benachteiligung oder Sexismus
ist trotzdem echt. Simon, warum empfindest
du denn unsere aktuelle Debattenkultur
-als problematisch?
-Also ich vertrete die Meinung, dass man
mit allen Personen diskutieren
sollte. Und ich bin für eine rege öffentliche
Diskussion mit allen Menschen und es herrscht
immer mehr so eine Meinung
von wegen so "Man darf mit den Leuten
nicht reden, weil die sind zu rechts."
Es gibt so eine Aufteilung
zwischen gut und böse und dann kommt direkt
die Kontaktschuld, sowas wie "Er
hat einmal mit mit dieser Person geredet,
also ist er auch rechts." Und gegen solche
Sachen bin ich, man sollte da wirklich
frei mit allen diskutieren und man
sollte sich auch immer bewusst sein,
dass es bei manchen Themen kein
richtig oder falsch gibt. Natürlich kann man sich
auch über die Fakten streiten,
aber teilweise ist es auch eine Sache
von unterschiedlichen Prinzipien.
Also wenn es jetzt z.B. ums Thema Corona
oder sowas geht: Natürlich kann man
sich über die Fakten streiten, wieviel bringt
welche Maßnahme. Aber selbst wenn wir uns
einig wären bei den Fakten, gäbe
es trotzdem unterschiedliche
Meinungen, weil die Leute unterschiedliche Haltungen
-zum Thema Freiheit und Gesundheit haben.
-Und hast du manchmal das Gefühl, dass du
Angst hast, deine ehrliche
Meinung zu sagen? Angst vor einem Shitstorm?
Ja genau, man hat Angst vor einem
Shitstorm. Und auch ganz witzig:
Bevor ich hier her gekommen bin, war
ich beim Friseur. Die, die mir die Haare
geschnitten hat, die war
übertrieben links. Also das hat man ihr direkt
angesehen, und die hat es auch gesagt,
dass sie sehr links ist. Und die hat z.B.
mal eine Rede eines AfD-Politikers
gesehen, wo sie eigentlich der Meinung
war, dass der eigentlich da viele
gute Sachen gesagt hat. Aber sie hat gesagt,
sie hat sich nicht getraut, es zu teilen,
weil sie hätte Angst, was es dann
für Folgen hätte. Dann wird es direkt
heißen "Ah, du bist jetzt auch rechts,
-weil du das gepostet hast." oder sowas.
-Ja, BRKN?
Also kurz zu der Sache: Das Ding ist
Meinungen. Rassismus ist keine Meinung.
Und wenn du ein Video von der AfD
teilst, auch wenn der vielleicht gerade
in diesem Kontext etwas gesagt hat,
was vielleicht ganz okay ist, darf man
es niemals ohne den Kontext
betrachten. Und die AfD ist eine faschistische,
rassistische Nazipartei. Und in dem Moment,
wo ich mit jemandem von der AfD
rede, ein Video von der AfD teile,
biete ich diesen Rassisten eine Plattform.
Also du als Weißer kannst gerne
mit Neonazis sprechen, mit AfD-Wählern
und Wählerinnen sprechen. Ich möchte
mich nicht mit Leuten auseinandersetzen,
-die mich tot sehen wollen.
-Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie dich tot
-sehen wollen.
-Lass mich bitte aussprechen, weil das
macht mich wirklich...Also ich finde
das so problematisch, dass es bagatellisiert
wird, so "Das ist eine Meinung wie jede
andere, die AfD ist Teil des Diskurses."
Nein, es gab hier in Deutschland
einen Genozid, der genau auf diesen Ideen
basiert hat. Meine Vorfahren,
meine jüdischen Vorfahren, sind
in diesem Genozid gestorben und ich möchte
nicht, dass diese Ideen einfach
als eine Meinung gelten, mit der wir uns
gerne auseinandersetzen können.
Da würde es dich nicht
interessieren, wie die zu ihrer Position kommen?
Ich weiß das schon.
Ich weiß das schon, okay?
Ja, aber vielleicht
könntest du auch ihre Meinung ändern.
Das ist nicht meine Rolle, es ist
nicht meine Rolle, komplett entmenschlicht
-zu sein.
-Also dich interessiert es nicht, dass
-quasi..
-Ich kenne das. Mein Großvater ist, wenn du
so willst, das Pendant von AfD. Er war
ganz lange bis zu seinem Tod ein extrem
rechter. Ich kenne diese Meinung. Ich habe
mich damit auseinander gesetzt und es ist
nicht in meinem Interesse zu versuchen,
Menschen von einer Menschlichkeit
-zu überzeugen.
-Ich weiß, das ist sehr, sehr emotional
aufgeladen das Thema. Deswegen ist es schwierig,
manche Sachen stehen zu lassen.
Aber ich habe da ein konkretes
Beispiel, über das ich mit euch gerne nochmal
genauer sprechen möchte. Und zwar:
Es gab bei der Folge zum Thema Abtreibung
den Fall, dass hier auf dem Feld
ein Gast war, der hier überhaupt nichts
Problematisches gesagt hat, aber nach der Veröffentlichung
hat sich herausgestellt,
dass er dazu aufruft, keine Masken
zu tragen, dass er die Corona-Maßnahmen
mit der Politik im Nationalsozialismus
gleichstellt. Also sehr schräge Vergleiche
und ein Punkt, wo das ZDF und diese Sendung,
die Redaktion, eigentlich sofort
gesagt hätte: Hätte man das vorher
gewusst, er wäre nicht eingeladen worden.
Also rote Linie, das bedauert
die Redaktion auch. Und da stelle
ich die Frage an euch: Wäre das denn
richtig, dass da die rote Linie ist?
Also muss es Grenzen geben? Wo sind
die Grenzen und wer setzt diese Grenzen?
Für mich ist das keine rote Grenze,
vorallem wenn es gar nicht um das Thema
ging. Es ging ja in dem Fall nicht
um das Thema Corona. Als wäre eine Person,
wenn sie zu einer Sache eine fragwürdige
Meinung hat, eine Person, die zu allen
Themen eine fragwürdige Meinung hat.
"Das ist eine Person, die kann nur falsche
Sachen sagen und nie richtig liegen."
Und das finde ich ein bisschen irreführend.
-BRKN, was sagst du dazu?
-Also es gibt so einen berühmten Satz, also
ich weiß nicht ob der berühmt
ist, aber man sagt, man kann Zitate nie
ohne den Kontext anwenden und man
kann auch einer Person kein Spotlight geben
ohne den Kontext. Das heißt, wenn ich dieser Person,
auch wenn wir nur über
das Wetter reden, ein Spotlight
gebe und sie aber abseits von unserer
Wetter-Diskussion sehr gefährliche
Sachen verbreitet, dann - ob ich das will
oder nicht, es ist scheißegal - gebe
ich auch dieser Seite der Person...Also
ich mache die Person berühmter und unterstütze
damit indirekt oder direkt
-auch diese Seite der Person.
-Emilia, was würdest du denn sagen? Wurde
da eine Grenze überschritten? Wo ist
die Grenze und wer entscheidet das?
Wenn es menschenverachtende
Meinungen und Positionen gibt, dann sollten denen
einfach keine Bühne gegeben werden.
Es soll einfach so sein. Wenn Menschen
anderen Schmerzen zufügen wollen,
dann müssen wir das als Gesellschaft als rote
-Linie sehen.
-Auf Basis des Grundgesetzes, oder wie kann
-man das festmachen?
-Also Grundgesetz ist da und das ist schon
ein Maßstab. Aber wir haben auch die Geschichte,
um uns diese Maßstäbe
zu geben. Das heißt, na klar,
die Geschichte wird nie 1:1 wiederholt,
aber es gibt Muster und diese Muster
können wir erkennen. Also ja,
wenn eine Person, also ein AfDler,
sagt "Oh ja, wir müssen Tiere gut behandeln"
und er ist vegan. Das ist zwar
eine Meinung, die ich auch vertrete,
oder ich denke mir "gute
Meinung", aber trotzdem gibt es dahinter
-auch eine gesamte Ideologie.
-Kannst du das verstehen? Stimmst du da zu?
Also ich sehe das, was ihr gerade
gesagt habt. Ich sehe eure Sorge. Also
wenn es kontroverse Personen gibt,
dann riskiert man natürlich, dass man ihnen
vielleicht eine Plattform gibt und das vielleicht
dann die ein oder andere
fragwürdige Meinung oder sowas
gepusht wird. Aber man muss hier immer wieder
abwägen: Können wir sozusagen
dieses Risiko eingehen, dass das passiert,
dass man dafür im Ausgleich eine freiere
Debattenkultur hat. Und ich sage,
dass es hier auch gar keine
eindeutig richtige Antwort gibt. Wenn man jetzt
seine eigene Sendung betreibt, dann
kann man das selbst entscheiden und sagen "Ja,
ich möchte diese Person nicht
einladen" oder "Ich möchte sie einladen." Aber
ich finde, wenn jemand quasi Bock
hat, mit solchen Leuten zu reden und sich
für gewisse kontroverse Perspektiven
interessiert, dann sollte man nicht sagen
"Oh, es ist mein Prinzip, dass ich mit solchen
Leuten nicht rede, deswegen musst
du das jetzt auch übernehmen und du
darfst jetzt auch nicht mit solchen Leuten
-reden."
-Du darfst mit jedem reden.
Ganz oft ist kontroverse Meinungen für ein gewisses
Klientel. Wir würden niemals
darüber diskutieren, ob ein IS-Terrorist
oder ein Islamist oder so hier mit uns
-diskutiert würde.
-Doch.
Wir würden auch nicht darüber
diskutieren, ob wir jetzt mit jemandem reden, der sagt,
alle weißen Menschen gehören
abgeschlachtet oder so, darüber diskutiert
man de facto nie, das passiert
nicht. Nenn mir ein Beispiel, wo jemals so
eine Person, die so eine Position
hat, in irgendeiner Form in einer Sendung
gesprochen hat. Ich finde das überhaupt
nicht. Das Ding ist, wenn du immer
von Grenzerweiterung sprichst,
geht es immer nur um eine gewisse Gruppe
und gewisse Personen. Es ist
ein Code, um menschenverachtende,
demokratiefeindliche
Dinge zu legitimieren.
Ja, ich würde da gerne nochmal zu einem
konkreten Beispiel kommen, weil mir ist
in den letzten Wochen aufgefallen,
das hat mich persönlich sehr beschäftigt,
dass heute eigentlich nach jeder Folge,
die wir hier bei 13 FRAGEN veröffentlichen
zum Thema Abtreibung, Prostitution,
heute zum Thema Identitätspolitik. Es kommen
immer Kommentare von Menschen, die sagen,
sie finden es grundsätzlich - das ist
ein Zitat - "menschenverachtend,
Abtreibungsgegner:innen einzuladen."
Sie finden es "grundsätzlich
menschenverachtend,
Prostitutionsgegner:innen, Menschen,
die dagegen sind, einzuladen." Und das hat
mich zum Nachdenken gebracht, weil ich mir
denke, wir leben in einer Demokratie.
Gehört da nicht Meinungsvielfalt
dazu? Könnte nicht Identitätspolitik auch so
weit führen, dass einfach eine Meinung,
also eine Seite hier auf dem Feld
-grundsätzlich nicht mehr akzeptiert wird?
-Das ist das Paradox der Toleranz. Eine
demokratische Gesellschaft kann
nicht alle Meinungen dulden, nicht
die undemokratische Meinungen dulden.
Das ist ein Paradoxon. Wo die Trennlinie ist,
die rote Linie ist, ist
natürlich schwierig zu sagen.
Es geht aber nicht um undemokratische
Ansichten, sondern es kann sein,
dass unter diesem Video zu diesem heutigen
Thema steht...
-..."Ladet keine Rassisten ein!"
-...es sei menschenverachtend, dass ihr
überhaupt hier auf dieser Seite steht
und es sollten keine Menschen überhaupt sagen
Identitätspolitik... Ich zitiere,
ich habe mir das nicht ausgedacht.
Identitätspolitik sollte
grundsätzlich nicht zur Debatte gestellt werden,
weil es geht da um Rechte
und Menschenrechte,
um Gleichberechtigungskämpfe. Das sollte
grundsätzlich nicht zur Diskussion
-gestellt werden.
-Da muss man ein bisschen differenzieren.
Wenn es um Identitätspolitik geht,
dann spricht man ja darüber, wie im Detail
versuchen diskriminierte oder benachteiligte
Menschen sich hörbar
zu machen. Wie das passieren kann?
Da gibt's vielleicht ein paar Wege. Aber
dass diese Leute diskriminiert sind,
dass Menschen diskriminiert sind und da haben
wir angefangen. Wir haben angefangen
bei strukturell benachteiligten Gruppen,
dass die Gerechtigkeit brauchen,
Gehör brauchen, ist glasklar. Wer da anfangen
will zu reden, da können wir gerne
diesen Menschen gar nicht einladen. Du hast jetzt
von Prostitution und Abtreibung
gesprochen. Beispiele, in denen ich mich
nicht besonders auskenne. Aber sobald
hier - und wir landen nämlich immer wieder beim
Thema Rassismus, sobald hier
ein AfD-Politiker eingeladen ist, ist
das für mich auf jeden
Fall menschenverachtend.
Ich finde klar, wir müssen uns
nichts vormachen. In irgendeiner Form leben
wir alle in irgendeiner Form. Wir sind
nicht perfekt, wir heucheln in irgendeiner
Form immer so und moralische Normen
sind auch Konventionen, die diskutiert
und errungen sind. Man möchte
nämlich immer so einen Freischein oder so
ein Ding. "Erklär mir jetzt mal die Regeln,
was ist, wenn jemand ein Viertel
schwarz ist? Zählt es dann auch? Und darf
ich dann den einladen oder nicht?"
Man muss es leider immer wieder
einzeln ausdiskutieren, herausfinden, wie stehen
wir zu Abtreibung? Wie können wir uns
weiter bilden? Wie können wir sinnieren?
Wir haben es jetzt durch
einen philosophischen Diskurs,
durch Menschenrechte geschafft
herauszufinden, Rassismus ist kacke.
Darauf haben wir uns jetzt schon
geeinigt historisch und das haben wir rausgefunden,
das ist doof. Wir sind vielleicht noch
nicht an dem Punkt, dass wir sagen "Tiere
essen ist kacke." Vielleicht kommen
wir dahin und irgendwann haben wir einen
Konsens, dass wir sagen "Diese Leute
laden wir nicht mehr ein." Da sind wir gerade
nicht, vielleicht sind wir moralisch
noch nicht weit genug. Klima ist komplett neu
für uns. Wir lernen erst gerade, was das bedeutet,
wie man sich verhält. Aber
das heißt, ich bin kein besserer
Mensch, vielleicht habe ich noch viel mehr Dreck
am Stecken, weil ich jeden Tag
Schnitzel esse und trotzdem antirassistisch arbeite.
Aber vielleicht schaffen wir es durch
einen Diskurs, dass man sich auch dafür
schämt oder dass man auch das Gefühl
hat, Fuck, wir haben jetzt alle gemerkt,
das ist jetzt kacke oder auch nicht,
ich weiß nicht, wir müssen die Argumente
-austauschen.
-Dass wir alles erst einmal ausdiskutieren
müssen, das versuchen wir hier ja,
wir haben das ein bisschen versucht jetzt
gerade mit dieser Diskussion. Und deswegen kommen
wir zu den Kompromissen. Die sind
eigentlich das beste Beispiel für das gemeinsam
Ausdiskutieren. Weil ihr könnt
gleich gemeinsam die Köpfe
zusammenstecken und Kompromissvorschläge formulieren
für die andere Seite, aber
dazu gleich mehr. Erst habe ich einen
Kompromissvorschlag für euch und mal
gucken, ob ihr einen Schritt auf mich
zugeht. Die elfte Frage von 13 Fragen:
Wir sollten in allen Debatten vor allem wieder
zuhören, weil wir vielleicht
nicht dieselbe Erfahrung gemacht haben
wie unsere Gegenüber. Es sollte nicht
nur darum gehen, Recht zu haben oder sich
selbstgerecht und elitär überlegen
über den anderen zu stellen. Stimmt ihr zu?
-Ja.
-Okay. Alle sind einen Schritt auf mich
-zugegangen, du auch?
-Ja.
-Okay.
-Das hat ja nichts mit Identitätspolitik zu
-tun.
-Genau, das ist ein Kriterium, eine ganz
normale Beziehung von einer Gesellschaft.
Das hat mit guter Erziehung zu tun.
Okay, dann könnt ihr gleich gerne
bessere Kompromissvorschläge formulieren,
-wenn euch welche einfallen.
-Ja, aber ich glaube auch dass...
-Was dann?
-Und jetzt seid ihr dran: Habt ihr noch
einen guten Kompromissvorschlag?
Schreibt es gerne mal in die Kommentare.
-Es gibt halt einen Unterschied zwischen...
-So, was ist euer Kompromissvorschlag an
-das grüne Feld?
-Liebes Team in grün, unser
Kompromissvorschlag wäre:
Identitätspolitik ja, definitiv, es ist
sehr wichtig für unsere Gesellschaft,
aber keine langfristige Lösung.
Irgendwann müssten wir da aussteigen
oder auf die Bremse drücken.
Wenn dieses "irgendwann" der Zeitpunkt
ist, wo Gleichberechtigung für alle
-geschaffen ist, dann ja.
-Gerne, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein
-Übergang. Es ist keine endgültige Lösung.
-Wenn die Hierarchien aufgebrochen sind,
wenn die Unterdrückungssysteme
aufgebrochen sind, dann bitte ja.
Okay. Also ihr seid alle einen Schritt
auf die andere Seite zugegangen. Dann seid
ihr dran. Was ist
euer Kompromissvorschlag?
Also wir hatten uns überlegt:.
Wenn eine Person ihre Identität betont,
um auf ihre Diskriminierung aufmerksam
zu machen, dann tut sie keiner anderen Person
weh, sondern sie versucht
sich selber zu emanzipieren.
-Stimmt ihr da zu?
-Das ist aber ein Wunsch von euch, weil das
stimmt nicht unbedingt immer. Also
es gibt Leute, die ihre Identität betonen
und sagen "Nur ich darf dazu
etwas sagen, weil ich so und so bin."
Nein, die betonen sie mit dem Zweck,
Ihre Diskriminierung zu bekämpfen - gegeben,
dass wir der Person glauben und nicht
Lügen unterstellen - sondern sie werden
diskriminiert und sie müssen es benennen.
Und wie kann ich das benennen? Ich muss
sagen "Der Typ hat mich geradezu
du dreckiges N-Wort genannt." Dazu muss
ich sagen, wenn du nur meine Stimme
hörst "Ich bin schwarz, deswegen hat er mich so
genannt. Aus diesem Grund betont er seine Identität,
um gegen seine Diskriminierung
-zu kämpfen.
-Also geht ihr da einen Schritt darauf zu,
-könnt ihr das verstehen?
-Also ich weiß nicht, ob er ihren Einwand
-ausgemerzt hat irgendwie.
-Na ja, ihr könnt ja eure
-Kompromissvorschläge anpassen.
-Naja, du kannst das Kind nur beim Namen
nennen, sonst
kannst du es nicht behandeln.
Aber es ist eine reine Beschreibung.
Also wenn ich Sexismus auf der Strasse erlebe,
dann ist es schon klar,
dass ich als Frau das erlebe.
-Aber das ist Identitätspolitik.
-Nein, das ist keine Identitätspolitik. Das
ist eine Beschreibung der Tatsache.
Das ist keine Politik. Politik ist,
-wenn ich für Werte eintrete...
-Aber das hat Malcolm ja gerade gesagt. Er
hat gesagt, man muss es beschreiben,
man muss es betonen. Es wurde keine
Begrifflichkeit verwendet. Er meinte
nur, man muss als Frau sagen, das war
sexistisch, das ist mir
passiert, weil ich eine Frau bin.
-Danke.
-Stimmst du dazu?
-Ja, klar. Aber das ist selbstverständlich.
-Ja, klar, aber es ist eine Sache, auf die
ihr euch schon mal
einigen könnt. Besser als nichts.
Ich habe mich an mancher Stelle viel
näher bei den anderen Leuten der anderen Gruppe
gefühlt, aber an mancher Stelle
nicht. Also die Sachen sind viel komplizierter
-als zwei Kästen.
-Auf jeden Fall. Wir haben uns tatsächlich
auch im Kreis gedreht manchmal.
Ich finde an sich die Fragestellung schon
ein bisschen schwierig. Weil für mich
klingt "Brauchen wir Identitätspolitik?"
wie "Brauchen wir eine Repräsentanz
für marginalisierte Gruppen?" Und da ist
natürlich die Antwort:
Ja, brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ich wünsche mir, dass man zu einem
Punkt kommt, wo die Gegenseite nicht zu stark
dämonisiert wird und man
wohlwollend in eine Diskussion reingeht und denkt,
dass er sozusagen auch Gutes im Sinne
hat und nicht so "Oh ja, der gehört der AfD
an und deswegen ist er ein schlechter
Mensch" und solche Geschichten. Es kann
natürlich sein, dass er falsche
Ansichten hat.
Es hat gar nichts damit zu tun. Also
wie gesagt, ich kenne das aus meiner eigenen
Familie. Ich hatte einen Großvater,
der rechtsextremistische Ansichten hatte,
sehr engagiert in der Politik war und der war
ein super lieber Opa. Ich habe ihn nie
als Teufel gesehen. Aber Fakt ist,
er hatte Ansichten, die eben dazu führen
könnten, dass gesamte
gesellschaftlichen Gruppen vernichtet werden.
-Ja.
-Und das akzeptiere ich nicht.
So ein bisschen hätte ich vielleicht
auch gerne gelernt, was kann man vielleicht
besser machen? Und was sind so
Dinge, wo du sagst Hey, da konkret die Art
und Weise, wie Menschen
"Identitätspolitik" machen, das würde
-ich anders machen oder verbessern.
-Ich glaube, es ist voll wichtig, dass
selbst wenn wir debattieren,
einfach nebeneinander stehen können und uns
auch die Hand reichen können. Das ist
so etwas, was vor allem im Online-Geschehen
so total krass wegfällt. Und ich wünsche
mir, dass wir viel mehr gesündere
Austausch-Plattformen
haben, wie z.B. auch dieses Format.
Wünsche ich mir auch,
finde ich auch toll, ja.
Also klar, nur weil ihr euch jetzt
alle sehr nahesteht, seid ihr euch nicht
in allem einig, da sind wir uns glaube
ich alle nach dieser Diskussion sicher. Es ist
noch viel offen, wir müssen noch sehr viel
mehr darüber diskutieren und sprechen.
Und deswegen danke euch, dass ihr dieses eine Mal
mit dabei wart.
-Danke dir.
-Falls euch diese Folge gefallen hat und
bestenfalls zum Nachdenken angeregt
hat, dann freue ich mich sehr über ein Abo
auf diesem Kanal. Und wenn ihr ein weiteres
Video zu diesem Thema sehen
wollt, guckt doch gerne hier oben nach und hier
gibt es ein weiteres Video von 13
FRAGEN.